In fact, a troublesome problem is occurring in the Kingdom of Coleus.The
two
people who are fighting are his older brother, Grand Master Souther Coleius, and Aslan, and the people who instruct him.  We were all good brothers, but if there was an
all-out war between the Aslan faction and the Souther faction,
or if some suspicious person was aiming at the princess,
I'd have a big answer.
Karou, I
came all the way for you. We'll defeat this guy. You guys, please evacuate
so you don't get in the way.
Who do you think I am? It's okay. I'll
keep my promise. If you're at risk for your life, just shut up.  If you're a piece of trash,
disappear, you're watching the battle of the gods.Then
why did my sister have to suffer?I
think she'll hide and live safely.Death Please
make me even more happy.Bell,
I've kept you waiting.  Tayo The
Dream of Coleus, the Sword That Turned into a Slime When I Turned It Down November 1, 2023 3 episodes delivered all at once
DET